Michael Knowles formerly uh a sort of
third Stringer for the daily wire who
has rocketed to stardom on the back of
anti-transgenderism is now pretending
that words have no meaning and that we
don't have video of the things that he
said let me back up and explain it to
you the right has started to really be
titillated by anti-trans rhetoric and
the Wilder that the rhetoric is the more
the right wing cheers and stands and
loves it and we've seen this at CPAC
over the last few years the biggest
Applause lines at CPAC are anti-tran
stuff when Ted Cruz said my pronouns are
kiss my ass the crowd went nuts last
year and similarly when Michael Knowles
recently called for the eradication of
transgenderism the crowd loved it the
problem is that when you talk about the
eradication of transgenderism it's
natural to wonder well what the hell
happens to the transgender people are
you calling for genocide or what exactly
are you calling for and the blowback has
been severe against Michael Knowles so
he is now pretending that words have no
meaning he went on the Tucker Carlson
program last night of course he got the
heroes welcome for most of right-wing
media and again this is why they do this
stuff Matt Walsh and other right winger
has done incredibly well with the
anti-tran stuff so Michael Knowles got
jealous he wanted to jump on the
bandwagon and it's sort of working but
here he is claiming oh the left is
putting words in my mouth
I've been called all sorts of nasty
things by the liberal press talk it's
been nasty nasty curso I I tend to
expect everything but I have to admit
being accused of genocide did take me by
surprise that seemed extreme even for
the fake news media and I think it
surprised a lot of lawyers as well The
Daily Beast and the Huffington Post and
rolling stone and a number of other
outlets all spread this lie about me
they just put words into my mouth they
did never said you heard exactly what I
said I said that for the good of these
people in particular so presumably I
don't want to murder them and I've
talked about an ideology in particular
I'm not talking about eradicating any
human beings talking about an ideology
here they said that I wanted to commit
genocide and I said this is libel this
is actionable libel you know the libel
laws in the United States have quite a
high threshold to actually Sue this
meets that threshold it does not he is
not going to collect a single dollar
that I can assure you you think that
unless the news editors at The Daily
Beast and rolling stone and Huffington
Post and all the rest unless they're
completely illiterate they lied
intentionally and I think their lawyers
called them and said change the headline
or you're going to get sued into
Oblivion right well the problem is we
have the video we have the video from
his podcast and we have the video from
CPAC and he says we must eradicate
transgenderism now I'm oh but David he's
not saying kill trans people no I
understand I understand let's listen to
what he said first there can be no
middle way in dealing with
transgenderism it is All or Nothing
if transgenderism is true if men really
can become women then it's true for
everybody of all ages if transgenderism
is false as it is if men really can't
become women as they cannot
then it's false for everybody too
and if it's false
then we should not indulge it
especially since that Indulgence
requires taking away the rights and
customs of so many people if it is false
then for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely eradicate
transgenderism from public life and then
here he is on his podcast a couple of
days before CPAC that I called to ban
transgenderism entirely
I made the point that if you want if you
want women to have their own bathrooms
if you think women ought to be able to
have their own locker rooms and not have
to look at
gigantic gross men while little girls
are getting changed if you want any of
those things
you have to ban transgenderism entirely
it's not enough to say well you have to
wait until you're 12 or whatever all
right so ban it eradicated fine so let's
go through this piece by piece this is a
way of getting attention and it's
working and he's getting it he's getting
the heroes welcome from the right wing
he's been treated like a martyr like a
victim getting tons of interviews and on
and on succeeded no problem what you
have to understand if we want to be
reasonable people is that there really
is no way to separate eradicating
transgenderism
from an attack on transgender people now
I am not making the argument that he is
saying kill trans people
I'm not saying he's saying that but what
you have to understand is There's no
practical separation because if you ban
the thing that makes a trans person
trans which means being able to exist in
the world with the gender identity that
they have determined is right for them
you are eliminating trans people
in terms of what their identity is and
so you don't literally have to kill them
to eradicate them and of course these
are the types of postmodern semantic
linguistic games that the right loves to
say the left plays but they themselves
are better at playing them than anybody
else and again like I said yesterday
would anybody accept this explanation if
someone had said we must eradicate
Judaism no no no no I don't want
anything to happen to the Jews just
completely eradicate Judaism we would
all be reacting the same way most of us
are reacting to the trans thing with the
exception of some of these loons on the
right so it's working it's getting him
the attention the question is what's the
end game and quite frankly I don't know
but for now he's getting the hero's
welcome on Tucker and elsewhere and
that's exactly what this was intended to
do
did you know that every year 30 million
trees are cut down to meet the demand of
toilet paper in the United States alone
here's something really simple you can
do to fight climate change a little bit
in your home our sponsor real paper
makes toilet paper 100 from bamboo
stocks which keep growing forever no
trees are cut down it's shipped right to
your door in plastic free packaging it's
fluffy it's soft like regular toilet
paper you're not making any quality
sacrifice and for every box you buy real
paper donates to reforestation efforts
Across America through their partnership
with one tree planted so instead of the
toilet paper you're currently buying
which cuts down trees and wastes plastic
use real paper actively helping the
planet you can set up a recurring
subscription so you're always stocked or
do a one-time purchase the average
American uses 50 pounds of toilet paper
or more every year make the easy switch
to real paper you'll get thirty percent
off your first order plus free shipping
go to realpaper.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below